Speaker 1: Let's go to Pablo from Albuquerque,
New Mexico.
I've never been to New Mexico, Pablo.
Hi, David, can you hear me?
Yes, I can.
Speaker 5: All right, great.
Yeah.
So I'm not sure I really have a question.
It's more a while back.
You had asked why we should keep on bringing
up about the deaths of like right wing conservatives.
And it's sort of touching on that.
Speaker 1: Wait, hold on a second.
I asked, why should we bring up the deaths
of conservatives?
Speaker 5: Sorry, yes.
In regards to COVID deaths?
OK.
Or F. Why?
Pretty much like when all these
Speaker 1: let me see if I can.
So you're saying sometimes an anti-vaccine
right winger gets covered and dies.
And I said part of the reason to bring it
up is that it exposes the incredible hypocrisy
and also futility of their perspective when
they confidently say no one needs to be vaccinated
and then they die, and hopefully it will encourage
other people to get themselves vaccinated.
Is that more or less what you're talking about?
Speaker 5: Yeah, more or less.
And.
I the reason why I think is.
As you said, it just you have to they're confronted
with, oh, well, you know this.
Everybody was saying people on the right conservatives
were saying, Oh, you don't need a vaccine,
look, you're be fine.
You don't have to wear a mask, especially
with the mask being mandate not being required
on planes.
It does confront them with their own.
Sort of beliefs.
Actually, there is somebody that Joe Rogan
interviewed on his podcast, Megan Phelps Rogers,
who called Roper.
Speaker 1: Roper, yeah, I've interviewed her
as well.
Speaker 5: OK.
I hadn't seen that when I was actually curious
about that, but yes, and you know, she mentioned
how exactly being part of the Westboro Baptist
Church, she had a there was somebody that
kept on confronting her about all these ideas
that she had.
And it was a lot harder for her to once she
was politely confronted with all these different
ideas.
She sort of had to come to grips with that.
A lot of it didn't make sense to her herself.
Yes.
Speaker 1: Absolutely well said, thank you,
Pablo.
All right, thank you.
All right.
Yes, let's confront people politely when they
have incorrect ideas.
Let's take a very quick break.
We are going to take more calls in a moment,
so don't hang up if you're hanging on to talk
to me.